is there is there sort of good evidence
or obvious outlet or lot of evidence
that there is a brain level distinction
between what we call conscious thought
and what we call unconscious mind there
better be but we don't know what it is
what do you mean by brain level and
maybe we better get that down first
anatomical question is that you're after
yeah this is the naive undergraduate
question right so when I'm talking about
two different types of cognition okay
conscious and unconscious just to put
the label on it so I'm just asking how
clear is it whether a certain active
cognition is conscious or unconscious
for example can we point to something
happening in the brain we go oh yes look
there's a little conscious thoughts
traveling true not quite like that but
there are plenty of you're a scientist
you know and he said yeah first of all
you have to have a clear behavioral
distinction is that it's very very easy
the kind of thing in anesthesiology
colleges will test for you know are your
conscious or not it's really important
being able to tell and that what it
depends on is overall neuronal activity
there's a certain threshold of overall
neuronal activity there's no part of the
brain that's associated with it it's a
global phenomenon well that makes
perfect sense of me in it but that
doesn't exclude the idea that it would
be distinguishable at the brain level
even if it's not localized in a part of
the brain yeah it could be but he said
there's no evidence all right and there
do seem to be some parts of the brain
where which is like systematically
inaccessible to conscious right so so
basically midbrain brain stem yeah yeah
yeah so I'm clearly serious cerebral
cortical damage thalamic damage can
really you know not get out to go on
yeah so that so we know that that it's
not everywhere in an equal sense
that there are some strange enticing
findings I don't know how they're
standing up we've showed it on some
tasks which are clearly cognitive it
they have nothing to do with motor
behavior you get this action in the
cerebellum for novelty and that's a what
that means is is what as far as I know
wide open for speculative theory on it
it's an interesting fact that's the part
of your brain which tradition or you
know good scientific tradition says is
primarily involved in motor control
balance graceful behavior and so forth
of its coordination yeah that that part
of the brain should also be used for
coping with novel problems and difficult
cognitive problem that's really
interesting fact many of you have the
experience of thinking you understand
something until you actually say it out
loud and have it come in your ears
reading the paper out loud clearly can
have a really enhancing effect and I
don't think there's any mystery about
why that should be so you're simply
getting other agencies in your brain to
have a look at this material and give it
giving them a chance to to do whatever
they do so your your feeding pattern and
the pattern recognizers and the do I put
it with my students I say making your
you know paying yourself for making
yourself lunch is clearly futile trying
to bluff yourself and in in a solitaire
poker is clearly a futile yeah
why should talking to yourself you
already know what you say
why should that be not futile and the
answer I think has to be yourself is
actually somewhat divided and you're
getting one part of you to have a
conversation with another part of you
hoping that the other part maybe will be
able to give you some help
give give the first part some help and
and it does seem to work
you